the olympic torch relay continues in
tokyo
but it's largely ceremonial with the
torch bearers only allowed to walk with
the flame for a few meters
the state of emergency in the host city
has seen the relay taken away from
public roads
with no spectators
restrictions are also impacting local
business close to the venues
this fencing club across from the main
stadium has been told to leave its
premises until mid-september
because it's being used by tokyo 2020
bad news for a small business
already struggling with the impact of
the pandemic
with the sports industry already lacking
energy to now be told
there will be no practice area is an
additional blow
from a business perspective it's going
to be a big negative
in all honesty eight days to go until
the games and coronavirus continues to
cause disruption
on thursday the first athlete to test
positive under the organizers watch was
confirmed in tokyo
along with a member of games personnel
and four tokyo 2020 contractors
eight women rugby players from kenya are
also isolating after a positive case on
their flight
and u.s basketball star bradley beale
could miss the games
he's isolating at their camp in the
states with his teammates set to fly out
on monday
the american women's football team is
already in japan getting ready for an
olympics like no other
with no fans at all in the stadium it'll
be really different but
um but we have to like be
we have to like be able to imitate like
fans around us and kind of like that
sort of energy we have to feed off each
other because
we're not going to get that from from
any outside
like audience or anything like that no
fans and the medal ceremonies will look
different too
athletes who win gold silver and bronze
will have to collect and present
themselves with the medals
to reduce the risk of spreading the
virus despite all the complications
countries continue to send their teams
to compete including china
who have assembled their biggest ever
delegation for an olympics
all 431 of their athletes were unveiled
at a special ceremony in beijing
with the game set to begin a week on
friday
david stokes al jazeera